القوميه الامريكيه جيك سوليفان التاكيد
على الدعم الامريكي الصارم الامن اسرائيل
وحقها في الدفاع عن شعبها من الهجمات
الصاروخيه العشوائيه واقل البيت الابيض في
بياننا بحث خلال اتصال مع نظيره الحاجه
الى التهدئه ومنع سقوط مزيد من الخسائر في
الارواح وذكر البيان ان سوليفان اشار الى
الجهود الاقليميه المستمره من اجل وقف
اطلاق النار
قالت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي ان وزير
الدفاع وافغالا تاكد لنظيره الامريكي ان
اسرائيل مصممه على الدفاع عن نفسها ومنع
ادرار بمواطنيها باي ثمن وذكرت وزاره
الدفاع الاسرائيليه في تغريده ان التصريح
جالنت جاء خلال حديثه مع نظيره الامريكي
حول العمليه العسكريه في غزه من جانبه قلل
في بياننا الوزيره عبر خلال الاتصال عن
دعمه صارم لامن اسرائيل وشدد على حقها في
الدفاع عن شعبها من الهجمات الصاروخيه
للجماعات الارهابيه بحسب وصف البيان كما
حدث اوستن على وقف التصعيد وصولا لهدوء
مستدام واتفق مع جالنت على مواصلات
التنسيق الوثيق في الايام المقبله